I'm joined by military expert Justin
Crump who's the chief executive of
sibling and British military veteran
great to have you here um Justin we've
obviously seen that that escalation
going on just bring us up to date with
the latest on the ground currently in
Ukraine yeah absolutely so we've sought
this 1500 kilometers long front line in
the South not a huge amount of movement
in the last few days compared to earlier
in the month we saw Ukraine Mount this
very successful counter-offensive up
here in hockey oblast but if we zoom in
the city of Lyman in Northern Donetsk in
this area is of particular interest at
the moment that's been captured by
Ukraine this morning following about 10
days of operations around the city it's
been slower going than the advances they
had further to the west but they do seem
to have driven the Russians back now
from that and forced them back into
another position some way to the East
and this is key to starting to unlock
the top end of the oblast here which of
course have just been claimed by by
Russia so a notable setback for Russian
forces they're putting a brave face on
it and saying it was a heroic defense
but a defeat and withdrawal is still a
defeat and a withdrawal in this instance
and Ukraine is going to keep the
pressure up in this area and what are
the implications then of Putin annexing
these four regions in Ukraine yeah I
mean he's putting a big line down in the
sand it's all part of this strategy to
escalate to de-escalate we've seen that
with what happened with the pipelines
earlier this week and so what a week
it's been that we're talking about all
this but
um it's still unclear actually exactly
what Russia's even illegally claiming is
it the oblos boundaries you see here in
Black still obviously controlled by
Ukraine there is actually the territory
they're sitting on um it does seem to be
the Historical Area he's claiming here
so
um really putting a line down making it
hard for any future negotiations saying
Russia's taken this territory we're
sitting on it and we'll defend it with
everything we have so what does this
then mean for Russia's broader military
capability we've already seen the
mobilization of so far 300 000 broadly
unwilling looking reservists who've been
forced into action that again is a sign
of Russia's desire to escalate and also
the slight desperation they're in to try
and make progress and to try and end
this conflict on some sort of favorable
terms that was a button they've not
wanted to press so far 220 days into
what was meant to be a lightning
military operation you know it's not a
sign that things are going well when you
have to do this very unwilling gesture
and we're also seeing from here
increased pressure probably on Ukrainian
civilians as well we're seeing that
across Ukraine but longer range missile
strikes we saw one in zapper Asia
yesterday that killed 30 people and
civilians will continue to be targeted
throughout the region as part of this as
Russia builds up its troop numbers and
thanks to this referendum and seasoning
this territory illegally can actually
now use conscripts right to the front
line they've called 120 000 up in their
latest mobilization that happens every
six months previously they've not
legally been allowed to deploy on this
operation now they'll be able to so
there'll be a lot more people coming
will they be effective almost certainly
not but over time it adds Mass to what
Russia's doing absolutely Justin thank
thank you very much indeed for this
analysis